we just can't get enough of Star Wars
I'm G reg I'm J on we're gonna watch
from a bad lip reading of the last Jedi
mastic I think this is a song love
they're seagulls one but hey this must
be the sequel follow up this is a topper
war tear video requests from our patreon
Lance door oh yeah since I'm assuming
this is one of their music video ones
Lauren mentioned our patreon page would
do like a bunch of stuff that you've
heard us mentioned before but he does
music video reactions weekly so on our
patreon page today so many them get
blocked on YouTube so we have uncut
reactions over
[Music]
Oh justice party in the garden
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
servants that joke I don't I love the
randomness of the bacon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes mine
[Music]
[Music]
didn't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I hope this becomes canon yeah
[Music]
you you can stream this and contribute
streams and and those tiny fractions of
pennies to bad lip reading everywhere
music is Soltis really apparently no I
love the concept imagine these are
harder to do then definitely there's two
different challenges if you have like a
whole dialogue scene and then they're
replacing all the dialogue with you know
whatever funny interpretations of lip
reading they got you got to really carry
that off for a while here a lot comes
down to editing because we're using a
lot of the same clips for certain
different lines so you got to make sure
that it's not entirely distracting do a
lot of punching in and yeah the lading
of the footage because they're really
repeating so many moments then sometimes
we're doing different lines for the same
shots I love that they keep these songs
so weird
observational and conversational thing
and I just love the stick thing because
it's just so random and like the lines
about the bacon and then like Luke
freaking out towards the end of like
it's just a stick I know where stick
yeah I think it's really a break it with
my mind and like the build-up to like
Luke getting like really annoyed by this
yes I think the stick thing just makes
me laugh so much because when I
rewatched the prequels Yoda has a stick
but then he's also just flipping around
and fighting Count Dooku and then and
then fights Palpatine in the third one
and he's in the Clone Wars
he's flips and stuff I'm like wait a
minute do you need why do you have your
say or do you just like the are you like
that character from Ed Edd and Eddy and
this is your playing
this is your buddy shows up in Empire
Strikes Back you're like oh he's this
really old creatures old dude and so he
needs to see needs a cane to the pretty
cool like quit see I was ticking we can
do all this crazy [ __ ] just cuz it makes
him look more wise you know guy mean
Gandalf had a big old stick and a bunch
of other Lord the Rings people know
fuses the staff though there's stuff
that happens through the staff but Stig
just loves in this particular bit of
wood it's your best piece it has a force
ghost stick here it's funny but do you
have a stick
Oh stick or sky if you can come back as
a force go so you can come back with a
force ghost ghost stick I'm sure I'm not
the first person in the world to have
ever observed that right I'm sure plenty
of people before me have I just noticed
it upon re-watching December [ __ ] I
as a force ghost with a stick and in the
prequels he has a stick so something
tells me that's what they're commenting
on in to some degree yeah why does this
stick assist with him over so much time
and through different planes of
existence I always get a huge kick out
of any especially song based thing where
somebody is taking something mundane or
simple just way too seriously or is way
too enthusiastic like this is why on a
boat works so well for me is because
like the concept of just having a
walking stick is not at all
extraordinary but yeah they turn it into
like more it repeats and the more it
gets stuck in your head just the sillier
and the more amusing it becomes somehow
that little touch of having Luke across
from him just like annoyed by the whole
situation yeah and then it also makes
you think like Luke spending all this
time on this island alone you probably
would have like a board experience like
this you know in the scenes that were
not in that way I hope it is can't well
so I wonder if the song would still be
for the point the song is really catchy
I wonder if it would be really if it
would still work on just listening like
if I just heard it the first time
without having seen the video because so
much time what I thought would made a
lot of the lyrics so funny some looks
are genuinely just really funny but a
lot of what made them really hit was
cutting to you know absurd looking
reaction shots of Luke Skywalker so I
feel like with the visuals that's what
really made it funny and the bad lip
reading part of it too because you'll
have or at least some of us probably
have the actual dialogue in our heads
I've listened to the seagulls one stop
it now I think it's genuinely really
funny on its own I feel like the songs
at the end they may they can get them on
iTunes Spotify they're designed with for
the videos you know that's the way house
should be listened to on ironically I
just wanted lyric videos that's the
pretties always wanted to break in who
did that just we're a big video all
right guys well if you haven't done so
already subscribe to one of the greatest
channels in the world the real Regent
bad bad lip reading subscriber than
as soon as you can you could subscribe
to us click on notification Bell Lance
door thank you so much for sending this
our way buddy usually you're pretty late
but those last two months you've been
really early to sending over your
requests he's getting on top of it had
15 days authoring winter break he was
like whoa there's some serious fires
happening in the world thank God I'm on
vacation right now he's a firefighter
that's the joke and lunches fires he's
getting married in the summer so his
goal this year is to lose weight or the
wedding and you better because if you
look all chunky chunky monkey funky on
the day of your wedding she is not even
gonna show up so she's gonna body shame
you in front of your whole family by not
being there you know your family's gonna
do you know what else starts with L
Lance loser I've seen you don't book
whatever he just wants to look if you
feel confident then go for it dude
either way doesn't matter what size you
show up in on the day of your wedding
she'll be there to say I do